yeah welcome to a new video playing swap
from from Germany I forgot Matthias
Mueller I am somehow forgot the name
it's an international master i'm not
mistaken doesn't have it in there but
strangely enough why doesn't he have it
in them in the name okay yeah because if
you want us free IC account for for IM
you you need to you need to have it in
the in the account name so we have a
quite weird position it's a bit like
cattle on with the strong mission on g2
the question is how to how to continue
now you can even think about Knight c3
this is not a bad thing maybe maybe just
do that and just accept this pawn on c3
because the g2 Bishop is just a very
strong if it takes on c3 itself not
exactly helping its development
and so what now yeah probably night 95
is what is intending to do ok Ruger
belongs here anyway Pro problem Bishop
Bishop f4 like b5 yeah many ways to to
improve also on Bishop e3 and puzzle not
sure let's let's not spend too much time
it doesn't help at the end to have
nothing on the clock and probably
comfortable in many ways so not try to
be too exact you
night just night be three yeah but he
can maybe take some
all night to be five million not easy
yeah come on let's play this this is the
most aggressive continuation attending
9700 Bishop g7 on the right red moment
Oh goober up c7 now you can take
probably what about this move isn't this
just good what is he doing now takes
Queen takes lots lots of pieces saying
now place b6 I can grab the wrong night
eggs I take the bishop so probably
Bishop takes but Quincy five is in a
very awkward pin yeah
and I didn't really see that move okay
that can take be some
that there should be five
should be a truck the eight
hmm quite quite strange all this yeah I
didn't see rook c8 at all this is all
based on concrete calculation if I'm not
winning a pawn here then I'm worse
strategically
yeah this is not good at all maybe 96's
now an irritating threat so he needs to
take rook takes that's probably yeah I
can do that then Quincy seven it's not
completely completely idiotic
yeah but he can he can play can play a
Quincy seven ok not what I wanted to do
the biggest issue is the time actually
it's still probably a okay for white in
terms of equality and not any any
advantage I don't want to exchange
Queens I need to disturb this night and
I need to Queen for that Roxy 1b6 Bishop
c6 something like this would put still
be okay always allowing this without any
any big big fight okay how to get rid of
this maybe group before
Joey five looks like the way to go k
didn't do that and this wasn't bad i
mean it can do that 45 seconds
yeah it's um it's tricky for white but
maybe something like hmm wait I to check
it to check okay then I need to take and
this is nothing that I wanted to do
yeah this is so now we're really good
for Black Tie Domi not too much to do
with 17 seconds
yeah absolutely no chance to to hold
this right this time the position isn't
isn't so so great for me of course but
with the time situation there's no
chance at all it's not really making any
any big progress but of course I'm worse
it's no no question Jack White yeah not
much that I can do end up in diverse
nowhere no question yeah yeah it's so
it's it's winning that like ass he can
play king before and and over yeah I
overlooked this rook c8 move completely
and this this really refuted all this
otherwise this is technically a really
nice I just overlooked the move um yeah
this this is good for white he's got
nothing out there I mean it's it's clear
that this this is excellent for white
butt down if you miscalculate such a
critical position it's it's a problem
it's it's just those bishops are very
strong and that try to make direct use
of that and say again I can play a slow
move like this intending night b32
exchanges his strong night this is this
for example the computer assesses as
almost a pawn advantage for white I've
done okay
hey I didn't see this year and now white
is struggling because the the structure
is worse and they cannot really avoid
this this trade will be five this Quincy
seven and this is an excellent PCM and
here maybe at some point here I think
white should be able to equalize really
getting the rooks off and try to draw
this that ok I'm was so download time
yeah this is very critical probably it's
lost these pieces are much better the
the bishop is just stupidly protecting
me five but otherwise it's been it's
just bad yeah he defended this nicely
and this was good and see it otherwise
I'm great but the distance is simply
agreed I was also considering um just
briefly cause this but he can just take
here and here somehow all those pieces
it looks loose but there is no tactic no
tactic for example like this you go here
and we cannot take on c5 or something I
mean the back rank or whatever there is
nothing yeah just in game thanks for
watching